[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à vous tous ce matin
notre invité dominique rodgers bonjour
bonjour retard bonjour je compte
toujours dans l'arctique
oui alors vous êtes professeur à
l'université des antilles maître de
conférences en histoire mais vous êtes
là ce matin comme membre d'une
intersyndicale que de l'université des
antilles l'intersyndicale qui regroupe
au moins trois syndicats principaux on
va citer la cgt la fsu et l'unsa 1 et
donc vous n'êtes pas venu nous parler
d'histoire du passé mais bien de
l'actualité brûlante qui concerne
l'université des antilles parce que il y
a une
un mouvement de grève à nouveau une
semaine après celui de de mercredi
dernier donc un mouvement de grève à
nouveau ce matin une mobilisation alors
c'est bien une grève qui gagne grève
même reconductible un préavis de grève
reconductible qui a été adressée donc
notamment à la présidence de
l'université des antilles oui tout à
fait l'université président n'ayant pas
répondu n'ayant pas commencé de
négociations nous avons maintenu le
mouvement
voilà je crois que les revendications
qui sont les nôtres sont justes elles
méritent au moins diane le dalo guide
c'est d'essayer de trouver des solutions
ensemble
alors on va à venir sur le fond les
revendications le fond du malaise qui
kylie a depuis plusieurs mois maintenant
on voir quelques années à l'université
des antilles et plus singulièrement sur
son pôle de martinique
mais quelle forme prend cette grève est
ce que les cours sont bloqués est ce que
les campus bien justement les accès
seront limitées enfin et puis je crois
que vous avez prévu également une
mobilisation au rectorat ce matin au
rectorat de la martinique absolument
être pareil en guadeloupe alors là en
guadeloupe et alors d'abord le mouvement
est effectivement sur les deux pôles
on a un cynique et guadeloupe ce n'est
pas un mouvement de la martinique contre
la guadeloupe ou inversement
ça ne l'a jamais été nous tenons à le
rappeler de manière très ferme
voulons pas la scission l'université des
antilles nous pensons qu'on peut
effectivement travailler ensemble on l'a
toujours fait depuis des années en bonne
entente
ce n'est depuis que quelques bonnes
années maintenant que d'aucuns agitent
cette cette espèce de chiffon et suggère
que les problèmes sont des problèmes
liés à des oppositions martinique
guadeloupe qui vous me l'avouerez
aujourd'hui sont un peu dépassé le
nombre de familles où les gens sont
mélangés les amis on se fait aux
fabricants que je pense qu'on n'en est
plus là et puis scientifiquement parlant
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens même
pédagogiquement me conviendra donc
action qui est prévue aujourd'hui donc
rencontre en martinique au rectorat à
8h30 mobilisation au rectorat pour
obtenir une audience auprès du recteur
parce que vous vous estimez que la loi
je dirais dit que le recteur les
recteurs parce qu'il ya celui de
martinique et puis celui ou celle de
guadeloupe elle saisit l'âme c'est une
femme je crois voilà c'est ça ont un
droit de regard sur les affaires de
l'université
il ya même un des deux qui est
officiellement chancelier de
l'université des antilles sont celles de
guadeloupe absolument et qui donc
effectivement un droit de vérifier la
légalité des décisions qui sont prises
ainsi que poignet c'est pas une question
personne
nous nous disons que la loi ne pas
respecter le code de l'éducation n'est
pas respectée et que nous entendons donc
que les recteurs jouent leur rôle et
dénonce de manière ferme alerte de
manière ferme de façon à ce qu on
rectifie le tir
et c'est cette demande que nous avons
nous l'avons nous avons prouvé les
malversations nous avons prouvé les
manquements à la réglementation avec un
mémorandum de 70 pages avec à chaque
fois des cas concrets
le rappel des textes les preuves de ce
qui a été dit jusqu'ici ça fait donc
plus d'un an personne n'est venu le dire
que nous avions tort et il aurait bien
du mal
alors je vous cite pas ce que vous dites
que vous avez pris acte du refus de la
présidence de l'université des antilles
d'entamer un dialogue
le 9 mars dernier alors que vous étiez
déjà mobilisés à la fois sur les campus
de fouillole et de schoelcher en
martinique et fouillole ans en
guadeloupe
et donc ayant pris acte du refus de la
présidence d'entamer un dialogue
vous avez voté un appel à la grève ce
jeudi un préavis de grève reconductible
mais on a vu un courrier circuler un
courrier du président de l'université
des antilles qui s'adresse à 4
représentants syndicaux en date du 16
mars
donc voilà 2021 donc c'est tout récent
réponse à vos revendications donc il a
répondu le président il est dans le
dialogue au moins écrit alors d'abord je
pense quand on est dans des négociations
syndicales on s'assoit une table on
promet on sort on pense écoute et on se
parle répondre par mail ça ne constitue
pas je pense à des ailes d une manière
légitime normal de s'adresser à une
communauté qui est en grève
des noms pour vous il ya toujours refus
d'entamer un dialogue se lance ensuite
si vous allez sur l'allée le détail des
réponses qui ont été proposées par le
président lors la lettre est assez
longue
on ne pourra pas qu'on pourra pas dire
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en gros j'y
vois là j'ai dit j'ai fait en gros il
dit simplement il redit qu'il a fait
déjà alors que si on pose un problème
c'est que ça ne suffit pas ou que ce
n'est pas fait et que le les voeux pieux
ça ne sonne le gong en sera responsable
a réalité donc c'est gentil mais c'est
pas une réponse
alors on le sait il ya des menaces sur
le la qualité même de l'offre de
formation à l'université des antilles
dans tout ce contexte cette situation
mais d'abord dans un dé communiqué de
l'intersyndicale
il est question de souffrance au travail
des personnels de l'université des
antilles alors que le terme est assez
fort qu'est ce qui peut expliquer non
seulement l'usagé mais que cette
expression pourrait être justifiée
souffrance au travail
les personnels c'est le terme est
justifiée parce que c'est la réalité
lorsque vous êtes dans une situation de
travail ou et personnel nous disant
réunion on avoue loi sur vous ou vous un
jury aux cris ou alors quand vous décidé
d'arrêter quelqu'un m'a dit je n'ai plus
un camp pour concret sur moi quand que
vous avez effectivement des gens qui
finalement se taisent parce que comme
ils n'ont pas le droit de parler ou des
qui propose quelque chose ils se font en
juillet et un moment donné ou
humainement on s'est dit qu'on va faire
autre chose nous avons des secrétaires
qui aurait pu finir
lanig mais pourquoi je le ferai puisque
effectivement je suis dans des
conditions de stress de pression
nous avons un vice doyen qui chez nous
est venu le premier show sont arrivés
l'état les insultes et les laisse les
les secrétaires en leur disant vous
allez prendre dû faire cesser
l'intimidation c'est la violence verbale
c'est une bonne partie de la gouvernance
de l'université donc non cela émane des
normes salman de certaines personnes
mais on a une gouvernance qui légitime
ce type de propos vous avez tous vu la
vidéo sur internet où on voit le
vice-doyen de guadeloupe effectivement
attrapé aux colles aux épaules puis
effectivement au cou à un de nos
collègues
le président préfère prend fait et cause
pour le vice-doyen alors que les faits
sont là ses doigts de loups première qui
a fait la vidéo donc nous ne sommes pas
responsables de ce qu'ils ont montré est
le président donc selon vous c'est une
méthode qui vient de duos de très haut
même quasiment 2 et puis qui se
répercute sur tout un tout une chaîne
résidents valides la violence et il a
fait un communiqué pour valider cette
violence est bien pourquoi les gens qui
sont violents ne continuerait pas à le
faire
on est dans des conditions
d'intimidation faut si vous ne faites
pas comme si et bien vous retire à vos
moyens
on vous où vous travaillez vous monter
des projets le président refuse de les
signer vous avez de vous avez l'aval de
la ctm vous avez laval 2-2 du parent
vous avez l'aval de différentes
instances qui disent le projet est bon
on le soutient on met de l'argent
le président refuse de signer lançant
réponse s'en expliquer ouais on va venir
sur sur la méthode que vous reprochez à
le stade jean qu'il le président de
l'université des antilles mais dans sa
réponse qu'il a fait aux revendications
syndicales concernant je cite c'est le
deuxième point de sa réponse concernant
la demande d'audit indépendant sur les
risques psychosociaux avec transmission
et transparence du rapport à la
communauté puisque c'est une des
revendications de l'intersyndicale
le président répond je souhaite
solliciter l'expertisé d'un cabinet
professionnel spécialisé externe
une étude des cabinets officiant sur nos
territoires a été lancée en ce sens donc
apparemment donc il est pas rester sans
rien faire il a dit qu'il a fait ce
qu'il a fait nous ne savons pas nous
n'avons aucune preuve et je ne peux pas
moi personnellement quand je vois ce qui
se passe dans mon université croire un
président qui nous dit que soudain ah
mais oui je vais le faible
r c'est que on en reparlera d'accord on
voit donc il ya une forte méfiance donc
vis-à-vis de la parole du président et
de toute la gouvernance de l'université
des antilles vous parlez de méthodes
justement vous y faites allusion c'est
ce que vous reprochez aussi une méthode
non seulement autoritaire mais
autocratique en fait c'est ça aux
professeurs et agents qui par ailleurs
est un excellent professeur de médecine
reconnu par tous et par tous mais qu'est
ce que vous dites on peut être à la fois
un bon spécialiste dans son domaine un
bon professeur de médecine et puis pas
un si bon que ça professeur de un
président d université
ce sont des qualités complètement
différent je dirais même que
culturellement nous avons parfois des
preuves de médecine qui sont des
mandarins et qui ont une conception du
pouvoir qui est je décide vous faites
mais ce qu'ils ne s'inquiètent pas de
comment on fait pour arriver à faire
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas une
critique au lot de je pense que c'est
pas une critique quoi monsieur gentil
c'était la réalité d'un fonctionnement
peut-être que médical qui est différent
de ce que l'on de la main longtemps
fonctionné dans une université française
où effectivement la règle c'est celle de
la collégialité
c'est celle de la concertation c'est
celle du dialogue et où effectivement on
prend le temps de discuter de co
construire avec les gens avec non pas
seulement d'ailleurs les gens mais aussi
les étudiants
voilà donc on est dans des mouvements
dans des cultures différentes et le
problème c'est qu'à un moment donné si
on n'est pas capable de se mettre à la
table des négociations
ce n'est pas capable de comprendre que
la communauté que l'on dirige n'est pas
satisfaite
eh bien on ne peut pas y arriver et
quand cette présidence cette gouvernance
et le professeur tad gens qui lui-même
dit que c'est une partie de la
communauté universitaire de qui n'a pas
encore digéré tout ce qui s'est passé
dans le cours des dernières années bon
ce qui a eu à faire ces règles mia qui a
beaucoup agité qui a provoqué quelques
luttes intestines
qu'est ce que vous dites quand il dit
bon ben voilà il ya c'est une partie de
la communauté qui finalement n'est pas
très contente de la tournure des choses
mais n'est peut-être pas si
représentatif que ça irait vers du mans
vous ou moi je vais vous en donnerai
quand on a plus de 150 personnes qui ne
sont pas d'accord c'est peut-être une
minorité mais c'est une minorité
agissante
quand vous avez même quelqu'un comme
adam aurait lunella qui dit que le
président de l'université se plaire à
monsieur le monsieur monsieur le
président de la ctm de son attitude
parce qu'elle ferait constater que l'on
est en train de dépasser les bornes
je pense qu il
voilà ça peut pas toujours être du même
côté ensuite moi je n'ai aucun lien
chair aiguillat jeudi au rien toucher du
tout je n'ai pas j'ai soutenu le combat
de madame lancé qu'à se taire c'est vrai
sur ce point particulier je crois que
lamartine qu'elle s'est honoré que son
combat était honorable pour le reste ce
n'est pas la question
nous ne parlons pas de personnes nous
parlons de deux cols de respect du code
de l'éducation nous parlons du respect
des personnes
ce sont des sujets de la tuerie c'est
précisément vous dites que justement
compte tenu de cette situation il ya des
menaces sur les perspectives d'offre de
formation
et puis vous dit toujours que le
processus d'accréditation justement de
ces formations c'est un processus qui
est précipitée et qui est fait dans la
non concertation et c'est ce que vous
demandez vous demandez là qu'il y ait du
changement justement des changements
absolument juste pour le public là lol
l'accréditation c'est le processus par
lequel on change l'offre de formation de
l'université
donc chaque ça se fait tout les cinq ans
ça permet effectivement de s'ajuster aux
besoins du territoire aux besoins effet
aux envies des étudiants ça peut-être de
l'ordre changement de fonctions va créer
une nouvelle licence par exemple ou
nouvelle licence professionnelle en
fonction des besoins au niveau des bts
qui veulent poursuivre des études
parfois ou bien effectivement va changer
un parcours va garder la licence on va
faire un nouveau parcours pour pouvoir y
arriver
pourquoi je parle effectivement
d'opacité c'est que en principe céder
les critères de choix la manière de le
processus doit être validée par les
instances
ça n'a pas été fait je parle très
concrètement pour les familles
on a les deux plus formations les plus
importants tant elle est sage on a plus
de 300 étudiants presque 400 qui sont
concernés eh bien on leur a demandé
c'est trop gros ça coûte trop cher vous
allez réduire point final qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des jeunes
on sait pas les collègues ont proposé
ont fait le travail
ils ont fait une nouvelle offre pour
essayer de fond leur demande de
fusionner ils n'ont pas voulu que l'on
proposé une semaine plus tard vraiment
ça va pas il faut faire autre chose et
ce qui est grave c'est qu'il ya une
décision département à l'unanimité des
collègues
et bien cette décision n'est pas
respecté par la présidence un moment
donné on est typiquement dans un
processus qui est autoritaire
irrespectueux de nos statuts et de la
tradition de notre université donc on
peut pas y aller alors dans dans sa
réponse
président de l'université des antilles
dit concernant la demande de délai
supplémentaire pour l'accréditation en
cours avec concertation et passage par
les instances légales ce qui est demandé
par l'intersyndicale il répond
l'ensemble des instances compétentes
sera consulté conformément à nos statuts
nous sommes dans la phase d'étude de
cohérence et de soutenabilité de ces
fichiers de présentation de deux
formations voilà et le donc c'est en
train de se faire là encore on doit
choisir les critères en amont et par an
après le temps qui nous est imparti
dominique rodgers est déjà terminée
juste quelles solutions se présentent
qu'est ce que vous réclamez en quelque
sorte la le départ la démission de deux
stages enquis de la présidence de
l'université des antilles on pourrait
s'orienter vers vers savez cette demande
précise et concrète pourquoi pas si le
président n'est pas capable se mettre la
table des négociations et de répondre
précisément aux questions qui lui sont
posées
je ne vois pas comment on peut s'en
sortir autrement normalement son mandat
court jusqu'en s'achève en août mais ils
butent 2021 dans cette année cette année
ces quelques mois on peut pas le laisser
terminer
est ce que quand vous avez des gens qui
seraient tous les jours vient dans votre
bureau en larmes on peut continuer à
laisser la situation se continuer comme
ça moi humainement je ne peux pas vous
demander un droit de regard du des
rectorats et du ministère concerné de
l'enseignement supérieur aussi vous même
et qui juste fassent leur travail ce qui
est prévu dans la loire leur demande pas
plus merci dominique rogers d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin bonne
journée
[Musique]